donc c'est 4 qu'il avait pas joué ça
l'autre fois
c'est 4 khalifs KF3 alors plutôt aussi
si ko normalement et sur des quatre
foubec 4 il peut refaire son C5 alors
non autre coquille c'est 3 et je
m'attends à D5 donc pour rentrer un
genre de Gambie dame
voilà on est peut-être fou B4 une
dragosine il fait plutôt faut ça
normalement mais oui
il peut en refait son nouveau répertoire
parce que c'est ça la spécifier de ce
format et j'ai envie de dire ça qui est
vraiment beau c'est que sinaka gagne ce
match un deuxième match puisque puisque
Carlsen a encore deux vies
ne peut pas être éliminé ne peut pas
perdre par contre
IKA ou peu et puis
[Musique]
une tronche de vente semi douteuse mais
donc au lieu de jouer 7 il a pris en C4
et c'est la fameuse variante où on joue
B5 pour défendre le pion mais on laisse
B 5 après bah c'est énorme bizarre mais
ça va du coup on n'a pas de purement
encore mais C4 est faible mais au moins
le fou va s'activer vers B7 on a une
bonne case en dessin qui éventuellement
les petites pressions sur sur des 4
bracket en quelque sorte et Naka il est
déjà en looser enfin ouais c'est en gros
tu as deux vies en fait c'est un double
élimination donc là c'est la c'est la
double finale entre guillemets
théoriquement on peut avoir jusqu'à 8
parties aujourd'hui parce qu'on peut
avoir quatre parties de la finale plus
l'Armageddon donc c'est en fer 5 2 + 2
parties de la deuxième finale qui serait
du coup en deux parties je préfère nul
aussi
erreur bon ce serait beau hein c'est le
scénario rêver Fab finale d'anthologie
dans ce tournoi
c'est l'équivalent d'un Grand Chelem
plus un méga mega Grand Chelem de fin de
saison c'est l'équivalent d'un
Australian Open quand on gros de gagner
ce tournoi si on veut comparer au tennis
Fab donc c'est comme ça l'Australian et
en avril il aura un deuxième tour il
sera l'équivalent un peu d'un Roland
Garros et donc il y en aura aussi cette
année avec un méga master de fin de
saison
donc là voilà pour vraiment resituer
l'enjeu Fab
mais c'est des grands Chelem tu vois ce
serait pas vraiment l'Australienne c'est
un grand chelem créer ça pourrait être
un nouveau Grand Chelem en Chine un
autre existant un autre Chili c'est ça
que des grands endroits là et ouais en
Finlande enfin etc ce serait voilà c'est
un renouveau c'est autre chose c'est un
grand chelem ça qu'il faut comprendre
donc forcément les deux joueurs ont très
envie de de l'accrocher à leur palmarès
avec deux tournois là tu auras un
qualificatif pour les playoffs et des
joueurs qui seront déjà qualifiés pour
la grande finale pour une giga méga
finale de fin d'année
[Musique]
classique des Flandres mais
pas à Paris Roubaix en Hongrie quoi
ça pourrait être un Budapest
et la finale à mon avis ce serait
l'équivalent d'un tour de France ou
d'une voila en fin d'année le grand
tournoi avec comme un tour de France à
mon avis c'est un peu des coups
d'attente là non bon il attend pas
vraiment tu bouges ton cavalier il fait
froid 4 fous prends bien c'est ouais
c'est pas du tout un coup d'attente
c'est un coup il guette il peut aussi
vouloir du cavaler A4 pour rentrer le
fou ou du X4 tout court il y a eu des
cinq il y a de partout
et ouais donc H5 écoute il veut prendre
de l'espace il veut créer des brèches à
l'endroit
j'ai tendance à jouer H6 quand on vient
m'embêter comme ça mais peut-être
accepter ce faire G6 mais ça m'embête
toujours voilà il a pas fait fois 4 donc
il provoque les changes il va prendre la
dame voilà pour échanger les dames et il
arrive vite sur B2
c'est pas obligé d'échanger enfin
peut-être il sera même bien sûr de ne
pas échanger les dames
pour pas tous les risques qui avaient
dans la 4G tape B2 et puis se dire ouais
bon j'ai joué pour peut-être attaquer le
roi c'est cool que je garde les dames
donc dame 4 par exemple
on va dire voilà dans la position après
avoir mais évidemment après faut
regarder de plus près après qu'il y ait
5 ce qui se passe d'ailleurs bon il a
fait tourner donc il tonnerre l'échange
des dames après évidemment
le provoque pas donc le cahier reste en
B6 il est pas un 4 pour les taper B2
pourrait peut-être prendre pour quand
même faire cavaler à quatre après
éventuellement
donc la tour donc peut-être pour B1
voilà
évite l'attaque et redescend B2 donc
comme ça si ensuite un échange d'âme
peut-être au moins la tour sera mieux
placé pour déjà défendre le pion un
petit échec or Magnus qui déconne le roi
donc voilà c'est pas un souci de se dire
ok étant donné de toute façon il y a
déjà
ok plutôt activer la tour via
H4 VH3 on verra et
il a fait ses cinq
de taquiner ce centre blanc qui pourrait
lui coûter un pion mais peut-être qu'il
se dit que les condensations qu'aupir et
recra il passera avec la deuxième tour
après là-bas donc après on G6
je suis d'accord avec toi
mais j'aime pas les
c'est peut-être pas si grave c'est juste
un ressenti qui me plaît pas et c'est
plus de 51 moi je mets pas plus de 51 là
non non bah après peut-être avec une
analyse approfondie et voilà mais vu
comme ça je sais pas trop comment
évaluer
un pion pour les blancs mais je me dis
ok bon peut-être il va faire un petit
rock ramener la Tour Eiffel
mais bon en soupe tu racisme m'agace
quoi je vois des problèmes à long terme
je vois que si on rock évidemment on
peut avoir des soucis
je suis en train de me dire que au lieu
d'avoir la double finale ils auraient pu
aussi faire un truc sympa c'est qu'en
cas de match nul celui qui avait gagné a
gagné le truc quoi s'ils veulent donner
un avantage
de 2
ouais ouais c'était une autre manière de
procéder bien sûr et la tête toi pour
venir voilà
qui a une action horizontale
et qui vient attaquer le pion C4 pour C8
tu vas faire penser 4 prix C4 dame prend
donc un petit Rogue ce qui est pro 5
j'en sais rien moi non mais c'est pas
fini enfin
après s'il perd un cas ici
qui boit de l'eau mais on le voit pas la
caméra
dans le noir
je sais pas
le doute cette ligue 2 un peu faible
écoute une finale Caroline ou young
avait de vie il en a perdu une parce que
carnaval de 0,5
mais bon ça joue on voit sur tout ça
voilà checker la position alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
donc Magnus a gagné son pion comme prévu
diawami les tours sur les colonnes BC
comme prévu et
on verra on va voir Magnus banque
je suis un peu non quand même
suis un peu mais quand même le pur H6
est plus protégé un moment donné je te
fais un janu sans C1 et je vais le
prendre enfin
je te fixe de partout je suis très très
bien avec les noirs
à 5 OK
les dessins
pour jouer la finale
voilà donc le scénario dont on parlait
7 et prend B2 qui a validée 4 peut-être
tu reprends F7 il prend à 3 donc j'essa
quoi est-ce qu'il a une idée cachée sur
tour d'essai tu fais tourner 4
j'entends
et tu peux pas te barrer avec le roi et
j'ai 5 qui arrive donc tu étais dans le
cadeau
il a pris bon j'imagine que j'ai 5
voilà et bon
c'est ça pour pas te faire
c'est étonnant mais on n'arrive pas à
terminer on va pas faire un truc genre
en force genre F4 et C4 G4 qui prend à 3
F5 tu prends tout un F5 E6 tu vois
ça suffit pas je crois que c'est le truc
pour le contrôle alors tu fais 4 ou G3
tu peux montrer très vite ton idée
tour d'essai
fuite cavalier Bondy ouais c'est ça
qui a eu des 7 tours à 8
et ça joue comme ça je suis 10 secondes
pour un carreau pour C3 roi des deux il
va sûrement partir pour ses 7 j'imagine
non mais attends
genre encore
je sais pas trop ce qu'on a quoi des
deux tours C7 sans me défendre mais
tomber 4 maintenant
il y a pas encore perdu mais
sur P4 il va tenter de défendre comme ça
il s'est réussi à repasser via E5 sur
échec D7 F8 tu vois pour essayer de de
serrer manus qui arrive pas à le finir
c'est sûr que c'est tour B4 le coup
cavalier s'éclater chaque c'est forcé
il préfère donner le 5 et garde à mais
attention ce qui Caro va essayer de
faire tourner fluide peut-être et qui
est G4 qui prend H6
et après revenir j'ai quatre directs
il veut quoi il veut tout fuites
F3 qui échange tout et garde le pion
passé
tu aurais pu F3 ça fait malin ça ferme
non tour B8 c'est un aveu de faiblesse
comme ça il pourra bouger son cavalier
F7 et ouais le pion sera plus emprise il
va revenir en G5 il va venir terminer le
travail bon ça se finit
carreaux une nouvelle fois mais par
contre trop loin
toutes ces pièces sont mal placées
maintenant
de faire tellement mal
et
le roi qui va repartir vers F4
et c'est abandon 1-0 pour Magnus qui a
fait très très très très très très très
mal à
aikao dans cette partie et qui prend le
premier point donc
Ikao qui veut nous rejouer son
estonienne en premier manus qui change
par rapport à l'autre jour où il avait
joué avec C5 et donc Kiko le laisse
jouer E5 puis normalement l'idée des
Noirs ici de prendre le centre et ça
fait une sorte de pire qu'un verset la
honte que tu joues avec G3
tu te laisses bouffer qui va les prendre
c'est comme un dragon j'ai trop inversé
il y a pas mal de manières de jouer mais
en fait ça va enfin c'est jouable pour
les blancs en fait en gros il veut pas
aller chercher Magnus sur le terrain
théorique il veut jouer une partie et
voilà donc pourquoi pas ça va jouer
donc Magnus a pris ok
sur la qualité d'air de
Rancho commenter
je pense pas qu'il commence bah ouais
mais bon
Daniel range on peut laisser sa qualité
derrière voir si ça évolue non mais en
fait je dois dire que sûrement un petit
problème d'air depuis un jour ou deux
quoi
fermé par l'humidité 50% de limitée
c'est très sec
il était à perdre depuis 10 ans avec ce
site
là le chauffage marche pas il essaye de
ça c'est comme les serveurs
issue ouais c'est
donc F3 pour essayer de redonner vie un
peu ses pièces
notamment fougères mais également
peut-être qu'il y avait les vins
non mais j'aime pas du tout en fait ça
m'énerve à cause de ces trucs de
dépenser moi il fait pas une grande
partie
il y a aucun danger pour le noir quoi
[Musique]
un petit peu la pression donc ça se
passe pour l'instant très très bien pour
pour Magnus donc B3 je vais pas les
carreaux qui consolide sa structure pion
qui peut développer le foot gaz noire
peut-être en B2 lutter un peu la grande
diagonale voilà bon et puis ça libère le
caler à trois aussi qui était jusque-là
la défense du pion C4 qui maintenant va
peut-être pouvoir venir en C2 pour
contrôler un peu les cases rebondir on
ne sais où mais ce sera toujours mieux
que 1 à 3
ouais ça va être place le roi pas besoin
de roquer pour la finale le roi du sera
plus actif en F7 quand j'ai 8 vous
pouvez jouer
peut-être tout ressemble vite autour des
8 je sais pas et puis on prend cavalier
prend qu'il y a eu 4 mais il devrait la
tenir quand même
FDK échange et tu sais
voilà je pense à faire
mon avis de base qui est Caro va gagner
ce match allez
mais plutôt moi
je suppose
c'est la même tête plus fort sans
qu'elle sait si
tu veux
tranquillement
des quatre et prendre je sais pas mais
oui en fait
mais naturellement j'aurais préféré
jouer avec les Blancs
après qui peut être chiant mais surtout
que j'adore la ligne de l'ordi mais
c'est hyper dur
ça c'est quand même chiant
mais
sur f4g4 C4 je pense nager 5 et tu te
fais complètement fixer
il peut trouver F4 mais F4 t'en prends
des trois c'est pas simple trouvable
mais pas simple il a trouvé c'est pas un
coup facile parce que en fait jouer F4
pour tout reprendre des trois fois F5 il
faut quand même être très aiguisé votre
affuteur il faut être très très affûté
mais [__] mal autant comme ça c'est
pas c'est pas une bonne chose après t'en
prendre deux trois tempo il aurait pu
aussi faire H3 qui était aussi une
option du coup tu auras ça tu
reviendrais 5 il prend HS tu prends des
trois mais c'est une puce de pièces plus
de pion quoi
il doit regarder peut-être un coup comme
cavalier 5 aussi est-ce que c'est
faisable
c'est pas un bon troc ça je pense que tu
dois apprendre et quand même jouer
l'autre finale après tu peux regarder
je sais pas mais bon
c'est ça qu'il active sa tour je crois
que c'est très bien joué pk4 mais bon il
en pouvait tous ses pions quoi
ouais mais il bloque un peu l'activité
adverse quand même
je crois que c'est bien joué
enfin ça peut ne pas être si Netflix
il y a un truc genre B6 3 bouge c'est 6
puis on prend tout reprendre et c'est ce
que c'était pris Carlson contre tous à
torové 4 encore désolé j'avais pas
j'avais pas oui mais tu paies raciste
ouais
il va faire ces six là c'est sûr
en fait ce que tu vas avoir c'est passé
quand même
ok
c'est la même on a eu la même idée de
manière de manière différente mais qui
est ici c'est joli
coupé
une pièce où ranger 3 et tu as raison
d'abord et je crois j'ai 5 et 5 amis il
prend nul
ici à mon avis il aurait pu
et ça repart on a vraiment le timing
maintenant
et il y a eu quoi trop pour pour Magnus
et hikao qui réfléchit d'entrée alors là
question c'est ce que tu tentes quelque
chose ou tu mises sous sur la dernière
mais bon il fait comme il sent
Caro normalement c'est quoi son
berlinoise et italienne
je sais pas ce qu'il veut jouer aux
autres
en face mais il doit se demander si ça
joue la drogue ou pas
clairement la question que tu te poses
c'est ce que tu fais la berlinoise il te
fait la nul non mais c'est vrai que
c'est bizarrement la partie c'est bon
c'est 5 ok c'est beau mais Nice qui
réfléchit quoi
qu'est-ce que je peux jouer contre ça
quoi
le coup quasi tout le temps
compliqué pour les Noirs je vois pas
trop l'intérêt de jouer ça j'ai 5 ça
peut être marrant comme quoi
pourtant G8 normal
[Musique]
et j'ai 5 ans
OK
on va voir après ouais c'est parti un
peu chaotique mais qui doivent mieux
correspondre au style de dix Caron après
est-ce que fondamentalement
[Rires]
un peu dégueu
F4 peut-être et mais bon c'est moche
bien joué mes quatre j'aime bien ouvre
le jeu logique donc
ça se passe mal il peut perdre cette
partie
à long terme
il y a pas trop de perspective partir il
a voulu trop en faire mais après
il a pas voulu tout jouer sur une partie
il a voulu commencer à mettre la
pression avec les Noirs mais c'est oui
bon pourquoi pas en fait c'est vrai que
plus tu joues plus tu joues de partie
plus ta chance en fait plutôt gagner une
seule mais il est enfin la règle de
muretas
[Musique]
qui te dit comment enfin ne risque pas
trop pour le gain tant que tu es pas
complètement obligé
tant que tu es pas obligé à 100%, tu
joues la position c'est que quand tu es
obligé que tu penses faire n'importe
quoi comment ça a vraiment pas tu mets
en ligne que quand tu es en fait ce qui
est parti bizarre de la partie carreau
bon il tente ce qu'il peut mais
il a pas été très menaçant en tout cas
il suit plutôt bon et après il arrive
comme d'hab à être pas lâché et ça peut
être si simple de de le battre dans
cette position mais après il y a le
temps quand même ça commence à être 5,40
contre 3 10 en vrai de vrai de vrai
[Musique]
du tout mais bon tu vois du coup
sa stratégie qui est un peu à l'envers
de ce qu'on ferait elle trouve ça
justification là-dedans si les mecs
essayent pas honte de te battre à la fin
pourquoi pas un peu risqué tiens il doit
il doit faire confiance à ses capacités
défenses à toi et c'est un set en cas de
oui pour la finale et oui on a peut-être
deux sept en 4 c'est magnifique en fait
c'était en quatre non c'est en deux mais
en fait c'est la finale c'est la finale
de la finale tu peux avoir deux trucs en
4 ah mais ça ça va être extraordinaire
il faut absolument qu'on commande juste
toutes les finales tout le temps en fait
ça va être magnifique
ah faut absolument qu'il car on gagne
les amis oh bah ouais bah là c'est la
rive de ouf
[Musique]
on a encore quatre parties derrière
ça ce serait beau non mais c'est obligé
qui car on gagne en fait on a faim il a
pas le droit de nous enlever ça avec un
ouf le porno
s'il gagne un connard tu manges mais
mais plaisir
on se fait le vendredi tranquille machin
et tout allez carou allez le hache
à ce moment là
j'écoute pas les gens à ma clio sur les
jantes
comme ça certains moments après dans un
monde idéal la finale serait cool
[Musique]
j'imagine c'est tombé 7 tours F6 je me
disais dame G4 dam gs6 s'échange d'un
coup je te fais agir tu peux plus
défendre F2
partout et je te défonce allez ko ah non
si c'est bo4 derrière en fait si c'est
bo2 bon il perd c'est pas si grave mais
si c'est derrière c'est grave en fait
on peut pas rater un tel truc en fait
attends
j'ai 8 ouais il le fait pas
il trouve tout les carreaux Magnus je
vais tellement le détester si il gagne
ce match non mais s'il gagne le deuxième
je m'en fous enfin genre bravo à toi
mais tu as pas le droit de vous enlever
ça en fait
c'est magnifique je pense c'est toujours
bo4 allez ko craque ça peut marcher de
gueuler comme ça il craque
il te fait F4 il dit ah tiens j'attaque
BIM dans ta gueule
non mais moi
souvent ce que je fais tu vois un truc
qui sert à rien non plus mais bon moi je
crois que c'est utile et quand je
regarde un match à la télé que le ballon
il peut sortir je souffle sur les grands
mais oui pour je veux que le ballon il
dégage encore nerf on s'y mettre je
crois pas qu'on puisse la gagner ça
en F5 allez on tente il peut tenter il a
l'air désespéré il est pas dedans le
frérot
allez
le H le wo4 tombe tombe
allez la déco
range si un moment tu fais sauter des
serveurs c'est maintenant le frérot
allez
[Musique]
pouce
oui let's go allez tourner quoi trop
allez le H e h le H le H le H prend le
Punto prends le Punto
bref 5 tours des quatre allez pourquoi
il rigole [__] il rigole comme si
c'était nul [__] tu as la première
ligne de l'ordi frère bref 5 tours des
quatre frérot ouais 5 on va aller le
ginkinama quoi
le roi F5 qui écrivait dans son chat ton
écrit partout [__] j'ai envie d'écrire
là dans le chat de chaisescom tu vas la
gagner frérot pas de panique
oui oui trouve tour des quatre ça gagne
tour des cartes oui tu l'as oui tu l'as
va le chercher va le chercher le double
B au 4
[Rires]
allez let's go
oui c'est beau ce qu'il fait FCO on va
monter allez
donnez-moi h h donnez-moi i I donnez-moi
car donnez-moi ah ah donnez-moi r r
donnez-moi
allez
il est là le frérot allez pousse
pousse-pousse tranquille pas de stress
tu as un Magnus dans chaque doigt frérot
allez on panique pas il va réussir à le
faire t'inquiète t'inquiète
c'est fait il va faire tourner
j'espère pas si gagne pas je casse tout
le jeu de merde il doit être facile à
gagner en fait je crois qu'ils sont
brouillé non
à un moment donné
qu'il pouvait monter
il tente
bon au pire ouais
faire tout ça leur dit d'aller trois
tours F2
ok ok bon c'est une tentative c'est pas
mal
du temps
roi des quatre allez le Fab la tête
on va jusqu'au bout du monde Fab on va
jusqu'au bout du monde on va lui pousser
le pion dans la gueule ça devrait aller
en progrès son progrès son progresse on
progresse gagne la gagne la gagne là bon
continuez à avancer frérot ça va gagner
ça c'est sûr F3 [__] j'aime pas
trop comment
ça a l'air de gagner en fait
ce qui va monter le roi en F4 maintenant
parce que tu te prends échec Roger Trump
j'imagine
[Musique]
ouais j'ai bien peur que ça gagne plus
les gars mais bon
c'était complètement gagnant
mais où il va là
il y a plus de place pour le roi là
c'est la merde
tu es complètement bloqué
c'est pas possible
comment il a raté ça il a pas fait
Tanger cet échec à un bon moment aussi
mais bon ok c'est dur enfin
je suis dégoûté et au final c'est
tellement de la
précision que
une case ou quoi et puis voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a raté il a tellement
mal défendu Magnus aussi
bien défendu longtemps mais non
peut-être après il a paniqué parce que
toi à chaque fois la première et qu'il y
avait des trucs je sais pas moi mais
là il y a plus rien tout est bloqué toi
et passive au jeu
j'ai pas compris
c'est pas simple encore en fait
le roi est pire que tout à l'heure c'est
pas
c'est pas facile en fait le rêve du
double et peut-être il peut encore
gagner celle-là
[Musique]
je suis un peu ouais la dernière fable
c'est reparti trop vite je pense que les
pauses en fait sont trop courtes sur ce
tournoi toujours triste de voir des
tournois comme ça s'arrêter toujours
pour toujours pour l'éternité bon après
tu vois en plus il faut attendre
jusqu'en avril pour avoir le la deuxième
édition
c'est sûr qu'on suit ça moi je rends pas
l'antenne
bon mais malheureusement on sait pas
s'il va gagner ou pas mais bon il a 7
secondes
non mais c'est vraiment trop des matchs
c'est obligé même si ce match là est
fini moi je suis je suis
très heureux
[Musique]
faire C3 et puis bon je le découpe
la situation
complexe
de fin
ce tournoi qui ont été extraordinaire
Fable premier
Grand Chelem de la saison
et pourquoi il croit un petit peu
un truc comme ça ça dure
j'ai du mal à avoir une autre manière de
remporter ce match maintenant pour Ikao
peut-être un mot
truc comme ça peut-être une gaffe est si
vite arrivé aux échecs faut qu'il le
tente il Caro c'est bien vu de ta part
Fab
complexe ouais dommage j'ai pas eu cette
histoire de fourchette
jolie
et sur roi tours
il va probablement abandonner ici c'est
vous que j'ai l'impression que chaque
coup de maïguste
il a pas perdu de tout le tournoi donc
ben merci encore d'avoir suivi ce
tournoi ring donc qui était le sponsor
du tournoi et donc on vous dit à très
bientôt dès avril pour la suite de la
compétition et compétition sur cheesecom
des jeudi prochain approche League pour
nous à 16h30 merci à tous ciao ciao